sin enviado más de 150 aviones de guerra
durante 4 días a la zona de
identificación de defensa aérea de
caigua hay que aclarar que esa zona es
mucho más amplia que el espacio de
soberanía aérea de taiwán de hecho es
tan amplio que se adentra incluso en
suelo chino y los aviones chinos han
volado más cerca de su orilla que de la
taiwanesa pero de todas formas es la
actividad más frenética en los últimos
años lo que ha servido para elevar otra
vez la temperatura en el estrecho de
formosa y para generar declaraciones
alarmistas el ministerio de defensa
taiwanés se ha dicho que este es el
momento más delicado de los últimos 40
años y ha alertado de que el ejército
chino estará a disposición de invadir la
isla dentro de cuatro años la presidenta
taiwanesa silent way ha alertado de que
si la comunidad internacional no
defiende en taiwán no será sólo una
pérdida para los juarenses sino para
todas las democracias del mundo la
tensión actual se explica por qué
razones primero porque en taiwán
gobierna el partido a diferencia de su
rival el coming tan es muy hostil hacia
pekín segundo que en china hay una
ansiedad creciente por una reunificación
que hoy parece inviable y la última es
que las vacaciones nacionales en china
suelen venir acompañadas de mucha
nacionalismo y maniobras militares